Salut, ici Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Mais bonjour, je l'avais promis il y a de cela fort longtemps, le sujet de l'antisémitisme me semble indispensable pour un épisode de Septante Minutes Avec.
Marie Pelletier m'a chaudement conseillé Tal Bruttmann, spécialiste français de la question.
De par la nature du sujet, je pense que vous allez voir que cet épisode n'est pas un épisode où je mets mon invité en difficulté en lui posant des questions gênantes.
Cette interview prend plutôt la forme d'une espèce de cours d'histoire où on passe en revue les quelque 2 500 dernières années pour observer l'évolution de l'antijudaïsme, l'antisémitisme et puis l'antisionisme.
Vous me direz si ça vous a plu. C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être en compagnie de Tal Bruttmann. Tal, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes historien, spécialiste de la Shoah et de l'antisémitisme, qui est le sujet que nous allons explorer ensemble aujourd'hui.
Alors, vaste sujet, évidemment, qui couvre plusieurs millénaires. Je vais commencer par une question très simple. Vous-même, votre rapport à la question, qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait que vous avez commencé à travailler sur ce sujet ?
Du fait de mes études, j'ai commencé à travailler sur différents aspects de la Seconde Guerre mondiale qui m'ont amené à m'intéresser à ce sujet-là plus particulièrement.
Et les choses étant ce qu'elles ont été, j'ai continué à travailler dans ce domaine-là.
OK. Donc un petit peu le hasard de la vie et des choix de—
Oui, parce que j'ai commencé sur la Grèce antique avant de passer là-dessus. Donc c'est vraiment du hasard et un enchaînement de rencontres.
OK. Alors partons de la base. Comment est-ce que vous définiriez, vous, l'antisémitisme et aussi l'autre terme qui serait l'antijudaïsme ?
Alors en fait, je vais commencer par l'autre terme. L'antijudaïsme est souvent associé, on va dire, à la période
prémoderne avant le XIXe siècle, sur l'idée qu'il y a l'opposition entre le christianisme
et le judaïsme, et que le christianisme a développé l'antijudaïsme par rejet des Juifs et de l'affirmation que la nouvelle religion doit l'emporter sur l'ancienne religion dont elle est issue.
Et par commodité, on a ensuite distingué un nouvel âge, une nouvelle période à partir de la fin du XIXe siècle, avec le développement de la biologie
et le développement des théories raciales, dont la première est ce qui a été appelé par les penseurs mêmes de ces théories raciales, l'antisémitisme.
Mmm-hmm.
Comprenant donc que les Juifs constituaient une race et qu'il fallait lutter contre cette race, donc l'antisémitisme. Alors, il y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire, ne serait-ce—
Ouais, ouais. Énormément de choses à développer qu'on va pouvoir explorer ensemble.
Mais il y a un point sur lequel il faut insister, c'est que en fait, on trouve des éléments qui vont être partie intégrante de l'antisémitisme.
Vous avez l'idée que les Juifs constituent une menace, menace qui sera déclinée sous plein de formes, du complot, en passant par tout un ensemble d'autres accusations, jusqu'au contrôle.
L'un étant évidemment associé à l'autre pour contrôler telle ou telle chose, un pays, un domaine économique, les Juifs complotent.
Oui, oui. Donc oui, énormément de choses à explorer dans tout ce que vous avez dit. Mais donc voilà, on a bien compris, distinction
qui est finalement pratique, c'est-à-dire que on ne pouvait plus rejeter les Juifs pour leur religion parce que, par exemple, ils étaient convertis au christianisme en Espagne.
Et donc on trouve une autre logique inventée, c'est-à-dire logique de la race, pour pouvoir continuer à les persécuter, continuer à trouver un bouc émissaire.
Mais donc là, on avance déjà à l'époque médiévale. Si on remonte et que je vous demande de chercher les origines de l'antijudaïsme, pourquoi est-ce que les chrétiens choisissent les Juifs comme ennemis ?
Qu'est-ce qui est à l'origine de cela ?
Il faut même remonter avant le christianisme. En fait,
quand la Grèce antique va découvrir la Judée, notamment, mais pas que, les Grecs vont découvrir des gens qui pratiquent une religion qui leur est totalement étrangère, un Dieu unique, par exemple.
Et on a des écrits qui remontent pour certains au Ve siècle. Ils vont commencer à imputer aux Juifs des pratiques qui sont en rupture avec la civilisation, notamment en accusant les Juifs au temple de Jérusalem de sacrifier
des êtres humains pour les offrir à Dieu et ensuite pour les consommer eux-mêmes.
Donc, il y a une défiance face au judaïsme dans l'Antiquité, tout simplement parce que c'est une religion qui est en rupture avec les autres religions de l'époque, dans le bassin méditerranéen,
où on passe du polythéisme au monothéisme et avec tout un ensemble d'interdits très forts qui sont totalement en rupture avec le reste.
L'interdiction de consommer du sang, par exemple, ou de manger du porc. Tout cela est totalement opposé à ce qui se pratique par ailleurs, de l'Égypte à la Phénicie, en allant jusqu'à la Rome antique, etc.
Donc, vous avez déjà des éléments qu'on va retrouver ensuite dans les accusations de l'antijudaïsme chrétien du milieu du Moyen Âge, en fait, qui vont tout simplement transiter.
Mais le christianisme est une religion qui est issue du judaïsme. En fait, initialement, c'est même une secte du judaïsme.
Sans rentrer dans l'histoire du christianisme, on a affaire à un nouveau courant, pour simplifier les choses, qui veut se détacher très rapidement du judaïsme et donc s'opposer à lui.
Ça va notamment être, Saint Paul va théoriser le proto-christianisme qui ressemble pas mal au judaïsme, va se débarrasser d'un certain nombre d'éléments comme la circoncision, l'interdiction de consommer du porc, etc.
En particulier sous l'impulsion de celui qui va devenir Saint Paul. Et donc on va avoir une nouvelle religion, qui ne nie pas pour autant d'où elle vient, à savoir le judaïsme, mais qui doit s'affirmer face à cette religion mère.
À plus forte raison que le judaïsme explique qu'on attend le Messie, tandis que le christianisme explique que le Messie est arrivé.
Donc il y a une opposition absolue contre laquelle il faut lutter. Il y a la nouvelle religion contre l'ancienne religion qui, du point de vue chrétien, n'a plus lieu d'exister puisque le Messie est venu et donc que la religion juive a tort.
Donc on va avoir une construction comme ça pendant plusieurs siècles.
Et durant la période médiévale, cette opposition va devenir de plus en plus frontale, notamment parce que les communautés juives sont réparties sur tout le bassin méditerranéen, mais leur présence induit par leur existence même,
que le christianisme n'est pas triomphant puisque les Juifs sont toujours là et refusent de rejoindre la nouvelle religion.
Donc il y a une opposition qui va aller en s'amplifiant. Le christianisme va par ailleurs connaître différentes crises sur l'ensemble du pourtour méditerranéen.
On voit apparaître, en particulier en Europe occidentale et dans ce qui va devenir la France, mais aussi en Angleterre, à partir
de la fin du VIIIe, IXe siècle, puis surtout à partir du XIe siècle, tout un ensemble d'accusations contre les Juifs qui vont totalement
se fossiliser et qui restent prégnantes jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire que les Juifs domineraient le commerce. Par exemple, une accusation qui est proférée par certains ecclésiastiques dans la région de Vienne en Isère et à Lyon, qui sont deux hauts lieux du christianisme à l'époque.
Ou alors en Angleterre, on va commencer à accuser les Juifs de crimes rituels, qui sont des enlèvements d'enfants qui seraient assassinés par les Juifs.
Et ce type d'accusation, en fait, il reste omniprésent jusqu'à aujourd'hui. Alors, par exemple, en Belgique comme en France, l'accusation de ce qui s'appelle historiquement le crime de sang, c'est quelque chose qui était très largement oublié.
C'est là un élément très intéressant et important, il n'y a pas de mémoire de ce type d'accusation, en Belgique comme en France.
Or, on se rend compte aussi d'un élément très important, c'est que selon les régions ou les territoires ou les pays,
vous avez des accusations antisémites qui restent très prégnantes jusqu'à aujourd'hui, tandis que dans d'autres, elles ont été totalement oubliées.
Les accusations de crimes de sang, par exemple, elles ont existé dans les territoires qui constituent nos deux pays. Mais à partir de la fin du Moyen Âge, elles ont disparu de ces territoires-là.
En revanche, en Pologne, jusqu'à aujourd'hui, l'idée que les Juifs enlèvent des enfants pour les tuer et récolter leur sang pour la Pâque juive est quelque chose qui reste profondément ancré.
Il y a une sociologue polonaise qui avait fait une étude il y a une quinzaine d'années, qui montrait qu'il y avait 13 % des Polonais qui connaissaient de source sûre, avec plein de guillemets, que cette pratique-là était une réalité.
Si vous posez la question en Belgique ou en France, la plupart des gens vont vous regarder en écarquillant des yeux, en vous demandant de quoi vous parlez.
En Pologne, en revanche, ça reste très profondément ancré. Ou alors, plus près de nous, si vous allez en Allemagne,
il y a un vieux mythe qui est né pareil au Moyen Âge, qui était l'accusation que les Juifs avaient des pratiques sexuelles très particulières.
Ça s'appelle la Judensau, la truie des Juifs, littéralement. Autrement dit, les Juifs s'accouplent avec des animaux et en particulier avec des porcs.
De la même manière, ce type d'accusation n'existe pas chez nous. Peut-être du côté flamand, puisqu'on a affaire à une culture germanique d'origine.
Et quand on regarde une carte d'Europe, on se rend compte qu'il y a énormément de bâtiments religieux chrétiens, des cathédrales ou alors d'autres types de bâtiments liés au culte chrétien, des abbatiales,
où vous avez ce type de représentation, par sculpture sur les frontons de différents bâtiments.
Et on les retrouve depuis la Suède jusqu'à la Pologne ou alors l'Alsace en France. Pour une raison très simple, ça correspond à l'espace autrefois germanique.
C'est pour ça que justement, je dis que peut-être que du côté flamand, parce que je ne sais pas, il y a une mémoire de ce type d'accusation.
En revanche, du côté qu'on va qualifier de francophone, c'est totalement inconnu. C'est même pas qu'on ne connaît pas, c'est que ça n'a jamais pénétré cette culture-là.
Un point qui m'intéresse particulièrement, c'est le fait que les Juifs, donc vous avez expliqué que les Juifs étaient définis comme étant ceux qui n'ont pas reconnu le Messie, ceux qui sont
adversaires idéologiquement, voilà, à ce niveau-là.
Mais ça va aussi encore plus loin puisque dans les différentes illustrations, dans les différentes iconographies, le Juif central, celui sur lequel on attire l'attention, c'est celui qui a tué le Christ, c'est Judas.
Judas, Judée, Juif. Et il y a cette idée encore dans l'histoire récente, même en France dans les années 90, on pouvait voir des dépictions des Juifs avec des cornes du diable.
Il y a cette idée aussi, si je ne me trompe pas, vous allez me le dire, que le Juif, c'est celui qui est responsable de la mort du Christ.
Évidemment, c'est un élément fondamental. Vous avez tout à fait raison de le rappeler, je ne l'ai pas mentionné. Mais en même temps, il y a quelque chose de très important, c'est que
cette culpabilité qui est portée sur le Juif ou les Juifs par le christianisme, ça fait partie justement de ce que j'évoquais avant, c'est-à-dire cette volonté de rupture avec le judaïsme sous l'impulsion de Saint Paul.
Là, pour le coup, les historiens spécialistes de la Bible ont montré depuis pas mal de temps, enfin depuis le XXe siècle,
que la figure de Judas a sans doute été inventée en tant que traître responsable de la mort du Christ, relativement tardivement dans l'histoire des évangiles,
c'est-à-dire plusieurs dizaines d'années après les événements,
pour une raison, si on parle avec le vocabulaire d'aujourd'hui, idéologique.
Par exemple, les historiens ont montré que les 30 deniers auxquels Judas a droit pour avoir trahi le Christ, c'est une absurdité, ça représente une somme misérable.
On ne trahit pas quelqu'un pour une telle somme. De la même manière, Jésus était une figure publique connue de tout le monde du fait de ses prêches.
Donc il n'y avait pas besoin de quelqu'un qui irait identifier Jésus pour les Romains. Les Romains savent qui est Jésus.
Donc, on a la construction d'une figure mythique ou mythologique qui renvoie évidemment aux Juifs qui ne reconnaissent pas le Christ, le Messie,
et qui incarne ensuite, pendant des siècles, la culpabilité des Juifs, qui évidemment est centrale comme noyau de l'antijudaïsme chrétien, qui va jouer aussi un rôle fondamental dans l'antisémitisme, où le Juif, c'est le traître.
Et comprenez par exemple l'affaire Dreyfus. Alfred Dreyfus est un traître, il est juif. D'ailleurs, il est choisi parce qu'il est juif par l'état-major français pour être reconnu coupable.
Et en plus, quand vous regardez, on le retrouve tout au long de la fin du XIXe et du XXe siècle. Dreyfus est désigné comme n'étant pas authentiquement français, il serait allemand.
Et si vous vous déplacez en Allemagne à la même période, le Juif est un traître parce qu'il n'est pas allemand, parce qu'il est de l'Est, il est polonais ou russe, etc., etc.
Donc le Juif est toujours un étranger. Et cette idée de la trahison, évidemment, qu'elle découle de ce mythe quasi fondateur du christianisme, est là pour expliquer que
la vraie parole, celle du Christ, a été acceptée par les premiers apôtres, sauf par un groupe qui va être le groupe juif, qui est incarné par Judas.
Un autre élément qui est très récurrent quand on observe les iconographies et les illustrations, les caricatures, même jusque dans l'histoire récente, ce sont les traits physiques.
Ce qui serait le nez pointu, crochu, les chapeaux pointus, les cornes, comme je l'évoquais. D'où est-ce que viennent ces idées-là ?
Et bête question : est-ce que c'est basé sur quelque chose de concret ?
Alors, le chapeau pointu, ce que vous venez d'évoquer, c'est la rouelle, c'est ce qui a été imposé, notamment en France au Moyen Âge, pour distinguer les Juifs du reste de la population.
Du coup, mais ça répond à votre question, on va dire naïve, c'est si on a besoin de distinguer les Juifs en leur faisant porter soit un chapeau, soit des symboles distinctifs, ce qui a été le cas également et aussi
pendant une brève période dans l'islam médiéval, c'est qu'on ne les distingue pas autrement.
Mmm-hmm.
Donc, si on ne les distingue pas autrement, c'est qu'ils sont comme vous et moi. Mais il y a aussi un élément, distinguer le Juif en lui faisant porter des cornes, c'est aussi le diaboliser.
On rentre de nouveau dans le jeu de l'antijudaïsme, le Juif et le diable, etc., etc. Donc non, il faut distinguer le Juif, la figure du Juif, en lui prêtant des traits qui seraient physiquement différents de nous.
Le seul problème, c'est que, et là, on touche du doigt
ce que j'évoquais au départ, c'est que c'est le fondement même de l'antisémitisme et qui vous montre justement qu'il remonte à très loin, bien plus loin que le XIXe siècle, puisque au Moyen Âge, il faut distinguer les Juifs du reste de la population.
Pour une raison très simple, c'est l'idée que le Juif est un ennemi de l'intérieur, quelqu'un qu'on ne peut pas distinguer, qui agit dans l'ombre et qui est une menace et qu'il faut à tout prix pouvoir identifier. Et donc,
la réalité, c'est que pour l'identifier, on lui fait porter
des vêtements différents ou des symboles qui permettent de l'identifier et qu'on va retrouver pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale dans toute l'Europe, imposés par les nazis et leurs collaborateurs.
Mais en même temps, l'idée que le Juif serait différent physiquement, qui est profondément ancrée, là aussi, d'un point de vue qu'on pourrait qualifier de culturel, vous voyez à quel point il est désamorcé par cette réalité-là.
Si le Juif était différent physiquement, en 1940—
Mmm.
...1941, il n'y a pas besoin d'introduire l'étoile jaune en Belgique, puisqu'on pourrait reconnaître le Juif. D'ailleurs, c'est assez intéressant puisqu'il y a un film de propagande français qui dit : « Que le Juif n'est-il pas bleu ?
» Voilà. Bah si le Juif était bleu, on n'aurait pas besoin de lui faire porter une étoile. Enfin, vous voyez l'idée. Sauf que le problème, c'est que le Juif, il faut lui faire porter une étoile pour le distinguer.
Donc, s'il avait tous les traits qu'on lui prête, on n'aurait pas besoin de lui faire porter la rouelle ou, plus tard, l'étoile jaune.
Mmm-hmm. Un autre stéréotype, une idée reçue qui perdure encore aujourd'hui, c'est la question du rapport à l'argent, la question de l'argent et du privilège.
Oui, oui, mais enfin, là, on peut répondre très rapidement, mais je vais développer ensuite. Mais prenez les 10 ou les 50 plus grandes fortunes de Belgique que je ne connais pas.
Moi, j'en connaissais quelques-unes—
Non, je ne vous demande pas si c'est avéré. J'allais vous demander les sources, les sources de l'histoire.
Non, non, non, mais c'est pas ça. Mais justement, c'est là où on est en plein dans ce qui est idéologique.
Si vous prenez les 10 ou les 50 plus grandes fortunes de Belgique, alors—
Mmm-hmm.
Je me rappelle d'un banquier qui était fort riche en Belgique et qui avait racheté les éditions Dupuis, qui s'appelait Albert Frère, qui était passablement riche.
Mais si vous prenez cette liste-là, je pense que tout Belge connaît les plus grandes fortunes de Belgique, comme tout Français connaît les plus grandes fortunes de Belgique.
Je vais juste dire un nom : Bettencourt, qui est L'Oréal. Et vous pouvez tous les faire, il n'y a pas de Juifs dedans.
Mais en même temps, on va vous expliquer que le Juif est riche, que le Juif domine l'économie nationale, qu'il s'agisse de la Belgique, de la France, de n'importe quel pays, alors que la réalité est tout autre.
Et on va toujours vous ressortir des noms qui ont été profondément ancrés, typiquement les Rothschild.
Aujourd'hui, vient faire une compétition avec les Rothschild, c'est George Soros, qui est devenu un emblème des antisémites un peu partout à travers le monde.
Alors que les Rothschild, même si on a affaire à une famille qui est aisée, ils ne sont pas dans les plus grandes fortunes de France, de Belgique, d'Allemagne, du Royaume-Uni, ce que vous voulez.
On a des fortunes qui viennent de la population chrétienne.
Et c'est là où on a un élément fondamental. Le mythe du Juif et de l'argent est profondément ancré et c'est là où on remonte à Judas, avec l'idée que Judas a trahi le Christ pour de l'argent.
Là, vous avez l'élément initial sur lequel tout le reste s'est construit, mais qu'on va retrouver quand j'évoquais, initialement, l'antijudaïsme entre Vienne et Lyon au tournant des VIIIe, IXe, Xe siècles.
Bah une des accusations qui est faite contre les Juifs de cette région, c'est qu'ils dominent les foires commerciales. Mais historiquement, il y a un élément important, c'est que les Juifs de cette région
travaillaient la terre jusqu'à ce que les autorités religieuses et le pouvoir,
et le pouvoir noble leur interdisent de travailler la terre.
Ne pouvant plus travailler la terre, ils sont devenus artisans ou alors commerçants. Et donc d'un coup, parce qu'ils sont artisans et commerçants, on les accuse de dominer les échanges commerciaux, alors qu'on les a placés dans cette situation-là.
On va retrouver ça
à peu près partout en Europe, en Pologne, mais aussi dans le Dauphiné à la fin du Moyen Âge,
c'est que le pouvoir politique va s'appuyer sur les Juifs en acceptant leur présence, autrement dit, en les tolérant, mais en même temps leur confiant des missions que le reste de la population ne veut pas endosser, qui sont très mal vues,
à savoir notamment collecter les impôts.
Si vous regardez une carte de répartition
des communautés juives en Dauphiné au Moyen Âge, elles sont réparties sur tous les axes commerciaux parce que c'est là où le dauphin,
c'est-à-dire celui qui dirige le Dauphiné, leur a donné l'autorisation de s'implanter en échange de ce rôle-là, de lever les taxes,
soit sur les échanges, soit les taxes internes au territoire.
Même chose en Pologne, où il va y avoir,
et là, on percute l'actualité au XVIe siècle, une grande révolte dans la partie ukrainienne de la Pologne, la révolte des Cosaques menée par Khmelnitski, qui est le chef des Cosaques, et qui va s'attaquer aux Polonais,
par opposition aux Ukrainiens, et aux Juifs qui sont vus comme les agents du roi de Pologne, puisqu'ils sont chargés de lever les impôts pour le roi de Pologne.
Alors, la raison historique de cette charge faite aux Juifs, c'est qu'on les tolère, mais en même temps, ils ont un avantage que n'a pas le reste de la population européenne, c'est que du fait de leur tradition et de leur culture, les Juifs
insistent dans leur société, c'est-à-dire le microcosme juif, pour que les enfants soient alphabétisés, notamment en raison de l'étude de la Torah.
Il faut savoir lire pour pouvoir étudier la Torah. Et donc, là où
les populations chrétiennes au Moyen Âge sont très largement illettrées,
par opposition, les populations juives sont très majoritairement lettrées, en particulier du côté masculin de la population juive, puisque ce sont des hommes qui étudient la Bible.
Ce qui permet donc d'occuper certains postes qui relèvent notamment des missions qui vont leur être confiées par le pouvoir politique, le pouvoir royal ou le pouvoir nobiliaire, selon les territoires.
Et donc, vous voyez comment est-ce que les choses se mettent en place. Parce que les Juifs sont culturellement lettrés, on va, en échange de l'autorisation de séjourner, leur confier une tâche ingrate au vu du reste de la population.
Ce sont eux qui vont être accusés de pressurer les populations, alors que c'est le pouvoir politique qui leur impose cette charge.
Et ils deviennent donc en fait le fusible entre le pouvoir politique et le restant des populations qui les assimilent comme étant les responsables de leurs malheurs.
Et par exemple, pendant la grande révolte des Cosaques, on estime qu'il y a quasiment cent mille Juifs qui sont tués, tout simplement parce que pour les Cosaques, ce sont eux qui représentent le pouvoir royal polonais.
Oui, oui, oui. Donc le pouvoir leur accorde cette fonction mal vue. Et donc il y a une équivalence. Ils sont vus comme les agents du pouvoir, ils sont vus comme le pouvoir.
Exactement.
Et donc ils sont détestés par les adversaires du pouvoir, les révolutionnaires, par exemple.
Et à plus forte raison, que vous rajoutez le christianisme par-dessus, qui en fait, comme vous l'avez rappelé, ceux qui ont tué le Christ.
Donc ça démultiplie le ressentiment à l'égard des Juifs.
Oui. Et donc y a un ressentiment important. Vous l'avez dit, y a le,
la question de pouvoir les identifier parce qu'on ne sait pas les reconnaître sans ça, avec par exemple la couleur jaune, par exemple le chapeau pointu ou autres, voilà, selon les différents territoires européens.
Vous avez la ségrégation physique avec la création de quartiers réservés, ce qui va historiquement devenir le ghetto. Mais qui se retrouvent un peu partout selon les territoires.
Dans le sud de la France, vous avez ce qui s'appelle les carrières. Plus près de l'Espagne, vous avez les juderias, c'est-à-dire des-- à chaque fois, c'est la même chose.
Tout ça, ce sont des noms qui sont donnés aux lieux réservés aux Juifs. On les tolère dans les villes,
mais en même temps, ils sont souvent, pas systématiquement, mais souvent contraints de résider dans un seul quartier qui, par ailleurs, est fermé la nuit, c'est-à-dire ils ont pas le droit de sortir la nuit.
Leur liberté de mouvement est très réduite. On les tolère parmi nous, mais en même temps, on les contrôle.
Vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure, y a eu donc une culmination à cet antijudaïsme au Moyen Âge, c'est la période de conversion forcée en Espagne.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler de ça et de comment ça a terminé, comment ça a eu lieu ?
En fait, ce que vous venez d'évoquer, c'est un mouvement beaucoup plus large qu'on,
qu'on peut remonter à la première croisade, par exemple, où ceux qui partent en croisade vont tuer les Juifs, notamment tout le long du Rhin, dans le sud de la France également, où il va y avoir une vague de violence contre les Juifs pendant,
en gros, du XIIe siècle jusqu'au XVe, XVIe siècle, soit lors des croisades.
Évidemment, l'assimilation avec le religieux, là, est fondamentale, mais vous allez avoir, lors des grandes épidémies, notamment la peste noire, des massacres de Juifs parce qu'ils sont rendus responsables de la diffusion d'épidémies.
Et là, à nouveau, si on regarde la période dans laquelle on vit, je pense qu'en Belgique, c'était la même chose qu'en France, l'accusation contre les Juifs d'être des vecteurs d'épidémies avait disparu depuis plusieurs siècles.
Mais on l'a vu rejaillir au moment du COVID d'une façon très forte, alors qu'elle avait totalement disparu de France et je suppose en Belgique également.
Mais là, c'est une accusation qui remonte au Moyen Âge. Au Moyen Âge, on a des vagues de violence contre les Juifs, notamment, et pas uniquement pendant la grande peste qui va ravager l'Europe dans les années 1348, 1349.
Mais à chaque fois qu'il y a, en fait,
une épidémie dans un endroit, on tue les Juifs. C'est devenu quelque chose de traditionnel au Moyen Âge et ça va culminer avec la Reconquista en Espagne, où là,
les rois très catholiques et Isabelle la Catholique vont mettre en place la conversion forcée à la fois contre les Juifs et contre les musulmans qui se trouvent dans la péninsule.
Ce qui est initié par les rois d'Espagne vont ensuite
être repris par les Portugais. Autrement dit, sur l'ensemble de la péninsule Ibérique,
il y a l'idée qu'on va christianiser l'ensemble du territoire en forçant les conversions des deux autres populations qui ne sont pas chrétiennes, les Juifs et les musulmans.
À l'époque, une partie très importante de la population est juive. Y en a donc une partie qui va fuir, notamment, du côté soit de l'Afrique du Nord, les territoires arabes, soit du côté de l'Empire ottoman, les territoires turcs,
entendus aujourd'hui.
Et ceux qui ne peuvent pas fuir, qui vont être empêchés de fuir, vont être convertis de force.
Ce mouvement-là va être très important puisqu'en plus va venir s'y ajouter l'Inquisition, qui va avoir pour mission en Espagne de vérifier que les nouveaux convertis
ne mentent pas et ne pratiquent pas leur ancienne religion clandestinement, ce qui va là aussi
donner tout un ensemble d'éléments historiques.
Mais à partir de ce moment-là, en Espagne et au Portugal, des années 1500, 1530, il n'y a plus de population juive alors que c'est là où elle était majoritaire jusqu'à cette période-là.
Donc, le judaïsme va disparaître totalement de la péninsule Ibérique. Tandis que si vous prenez, par exemple, l'Allemagne, jusqu'au XXe siècle, y a une présence constante des Juifs en territoire allemand parce qu'y aura pas eu d'expulsion.
Alors qu'en France, les rois de France vont régulièrement expulser les Juifs, puis leurs successeurs vont les autoriser à revenir, ce qui fait des mouvements incessants,
jusqu'aux années, là aussi, 1500 environ, où il va y avoir la dernière grande expulsion de Juifs
et il n'y aura plus de Juifs en territoire français.
Même chose en Belgique, où la présence juive quasiment
nulle jusqu'au XIXe siècle. Donc, on a vraiment, là aussi, des rapports au territoire qui sont très différents, même si on voit l'Europe comme un, l'Europe occidentale comme un ensemble à peu près uniforme.
Vous avez des territoires où il n'y aura plus de Juifs pendant des siècles, où même la culture qu'ils ont initiée va disparaître.
C'est le cas aussi en Sicile, qui est gouvernée par les rois d'Espagne, où là, vous aviez des communautés juives florissantes qui vont être éradiquées.
Même chose dans le sud de l'Italie, tandis que dans le nord de l'Italie, où ils sont notamment protégés par le pouvoir papal, comme dans la région d'Avignon, en France, les communautés juives vont rester jusqu'au XXe siècle.
Donc, y a énormément de variations selon les territoires et selon les pouvoirs locaux.
Et pour revenir donc à la péninsule Ibérique et aux conversions forcées, c'est quelque chose qui va donc, vous l'avez dit, mener à la disparition du judaïsme en tant que religion sur la péninsule Ibérique.
Et puis, on va voir apparaître un mouvement qui s'appelle, 'fin une institution qui s'appelle l'Inquisition. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler, de comment elle a fonctionné et qui elle a visé ?
C'est dans cette institution.
L'Inquisition, elle est pas liée uniquement à cette question-là. L'Inquisition, c'est quelque chose qui apparaît au Moyen Âge
pour lutter contre ceux qui viennent dévier du christianisme, les hérétiques, et qui va connaître, enfin il va y avoir énormément d'épisodes.
Par exemple, au sud de la France, vous avez les Cathares qui vont être la cible, là aussi, d'une guerre qui va les faire disparaître.
Et on s'inscrit vraiment dans un moment où le christianisme en Europe occidentale durcit sa tolérance vis-à-vis de, d'une part, toute forme de déviance dans sa religion.
C'est le christianisme dans sa version européenne qui prévaut, par opposition au christianisme tel qu'il est pratiqué, notamment à l'est, ou à l'est de l'Europe ou à l'est de la Méditerranée.
Vous avez les Coptes ou d'autres courants qui sont les plus anciens du christianisme qui sont pratiqués.
En Europe, il va y avoir, sous l'impulsion de Rome, une politique qui vise à vraiment garder une ligne orthodoxe, même si le terme peut pas s'appliquer puisqu'il est revendiqué par un autre courant du christianisme, un courant orthodoxe.
Et dans le même temps, on va lutter, mais là, ce sont les pouvoirs locaux, les royautés, qui vont lutter contre la présence des Juifs,
en particulier en Espagne et au Portugal, en recourant à l'Inquisition, notamment par une figure qui est devenue
centrale dans la représentation, celle de Torquemada.
Mais l'Inquisition en France, par exemple, ne va pas du tout s'appliquer. Y a pas de conversion forcée, par ailleurs, dans le territoire français.
Qu'en Espagne, à partir d'Isabelle la Catholique, on va voir la mise en place, en fait, d'une police religieuse, si on parle en termes modernes, qui va avoir pour mission de traquer les
faux convertis, ceux qui continuent à pratiquer le judaïsme clandestinement.
Ça va donner lieu à tout un ensemble de procès et de condamnations à mort, notamment par le bûcher, pour ceux qui sont accusés et condamnés de continuer à pratiquer la religion juive.
Mh. Donc est-ce que c'est seulement les personnes qui pratiquent en secret la religion juive ? Ou bien est-ce que c'est carrément
l'idée qu'il y a un peuple juif, qu'il y a des traits physiques juifs, qu'il y a une possibilité d'être juif par essence et pas juste par pratique ?
Non, non. Enfin, c'est l'idée que si vous êtes le Juif, et de toute façon collectivement, soupçonné. C'est vraiment au cœur de la théorie que j'évoquais tout à l'heure, la limpieza de sangre, la pureté du sang.
Vous avez les anciens chrétiens, c'est des termes qui sont utilisés, c'est-à-dire les Espagnols non Juifs, contre les nouveaux chrétiens, les convertis et leurs descendants,
qui vont continuer à être distingués comme étant les nouveaux chrétiens, qu'ils soient d'origine juive ou d'origine maure, comme on disait à l'époque, c'est-à-dire musulmans.
Et le soupçon pèse sur eux en permanence, puisqu'ils ne sont pas comme nous, ce sont des néo. Ils ne sont pas comme nous.
En leur sein, y en a certainement qui continuent à pratiquer-
Mh
...la religion, soit des générations précédentes, soit pour les premières générations concernées, leur religion.
Et donc, il va y avoir régulièrement des procès pendant des décennies contre des gens qui sont soupçonnés, mais juste sur la base, en fait, d'avoir été soit Juifs convertis, soit descendants de convertis. Y a pas de-
Donc les descendants de convertis qui ne pratiquaient pas forcément, mais ils sont descendants de convertis.
Mais ils sont descendants de convertis, donc y a une forme de péché originel qui continue-
C'est ça
...à leur être reproché. Donc c'est un mélange de-- la question comme vous l'avez posée, c'est un mélange des deux.
C'est ça. OK, OK, OK, je vois bien.
Alors, si on avance dans l'histoire, vous avez évoqué que donc en France, y avait des allers-retours, des va-et-vient, des rois qui les éjectaient, qui les massacraient, et puis ils étaient autorisés à revenir.
Et puis, voilà, des politiques, disons, qui ont pu évoluer à travers l'histoire. Si on avance dans le temps et qu'on va jusqu'à la Révolution française,
y a donc cette idée de citoyenneté, de les citoyens sont égaux en droits, qui va donc fondamentalement contre cette idée de discrimination entre les différentes religions.
Est-ce que cette transition se passe facilement ?
Alors, vous allez avoir énormément de débats, ce qui va être l'Assemblée, enfin, pas l'Assemblée nationale telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui, mais l'Assemblée, au moment des premières années de la période révolutionnaire.
Et en 1791, 1792 vont être discutées toutes les questions relevant de la citoyenneté, comme vous l'avez évoqué, avec des débats autour de la question : faut-il faire des Juifs des citoyens à part entière ?
On a là quelque chose,
et de la même manière, puisqu'on a à peu près la même culture entre la Belgique et la France et que vous avez hérité aussi des principes révolutionnaires,
c'est que jusqu'à aujourd'hui, dans certaines parties de l'Europe, mais c'était le cas dans toute l'Europe à l'époque,
les Juifs constituent une nationalité.
Par exemple, en France, vous avez ce qu'on appelle la nation portugaise, ce sont les Juifs du sud-ouest, entre Bordeaux et Bayonne, en particulier.
C'est que les Juifs constituent une nationalité comme vous avez plein d'autres nationalités. Et jusqu'à aujourd'hui, si vous prenez l'est de l'Europe, vous êtes citoyen polonais de nationalité polonaise.
Autrement dit, vous êtes de rite catholique, vous parlez la langue polonaise et vous avez une culture polonaise, par opposition aux citoyens polonais ukrainiens, autre religion, la religion uniate, la langue ukrainienne et la culture ukrainienne.
Et vous avez la nationalité juive, des Juifs ayant une religion différente, une langue différente, le yiddish, etc.
C'est la même chose en France.
Au moment de la Révolution et tous les débats liés aux questions de citoyenneté, et c'est dit notamment par le duc de Clermont-Tonnerre, formellement, et puis par l'abbé Grégoire qui milite pour que les Juifs soient faits citoyens,
et égaux avec le reste des Français, c'est que les Juifs ne sont désormais plus une nationalité, c'est dit tel quel, pardon, mais ils deviennent citoyens, ils font partie de la nation française.
Et à partir de ce moment-là, la Révolution française va inventer l'idée d'un État dont les frontières se confondent avec la nation.
Dans ce que j'entends, dans ce que vous dites, beaucoup de débats à ce sujet, sur la question de oui, est-ce que c'est vraiment possible de donner la citoyenneté aux Juifs, etc.
Beaucoup de débats, alors qu'on parle d'une population qui consiste à, enfin, qui compte pour zéro point trois petits points pour cent de la population. C'est juste ?
Bah, c'est à peu près ça, puisqu'à l'époque, y a environ trente mille Juifs qui sont répartis entre
deux grands lieux, Strasbourg, enfin l'Alsace, qui était territorialement pendant très longtemps, ce qui explique la présence continue des Juifs, et le sud-ouest de la France où vous avez la nation portugaise.
Donc c'est quasiment ça les deux points où vous avez à l'époque des Juifs en France. C'est un tout petit groupe, mais justement, ça découle des Lumières et de l'idée que même un petit groupe doit faire partie de la nation.
Donc évidemment, ce que vous avez évoqué très juste, on va avoir des débats à n'en plus finir à l'Assemblée pour décider si ce petit groupe doit être intégré comme faisant partie du corps national, ce qui va finalement être le cas.
À partir de 1792, les Juifs sont citoyens à part entière et c'est l'invention de l'équivalence entre citoyenneté et nationalité par la France, qui est le modèle qui va se diffuser dans une partie de l'Europe.
Je choisis de parler de la Révolution française aussi parce qu'on entend parfois que l'antisémitisme, c'est l'expression d'un rejet de la Révolution française et de son universalisme.
Alors, les antisémites du XIXe siècle vont évidemment rendre responsables les Juifs de la Révolution française, donc de tous les apports de la Révolution française.
Et si on pousse jusqu'au bout, Adolf Hitler va passer son temps à dénoncer les méfaits de la Révolution française, comme le maréchal Pétain va expliquer qu'il faut revenir sur le désastre qu'a constitué la Révolution française.
Et là, on rejoint les théories du complot qui sont au cœur de l'antisémitisme. La Révolution française devient a posteriori une justification pour les antisémites, la preuve de la réalité du complot juif.
Alors que vous l'avez pointé, y a quasiment pas de Juifs en France à l'époque. C'est plus un point au centre des idées des Lumières.
Est-ce que quelqu'un qui n'est pas comme nous, entendu chrétien, peut faire partie du corps national ? Et les révolutionnaires vont donc dire oui.
Mais on parle-- à l'époque, on débat à propos d'une population qui est résiduelle, mais à partir de laquelle
les révolutionnaires imprégnés des idées des Lumières veulent constituer une nation nouvelle, celle qui intègre tout le monde dans un même État, par opposition aux empires.
Vous avez, les empires sont constitués de plein de nations différentes.
Donc c'est une création de la Révolution française, mais a posteriori, ça va devenir la preuve de l'importance du complot juif, puisque les Juifs ont bénéficié de la Révolution française.
Oui, je vois bien. Et donc,
c'est à peu près dans, oui, il me semble, hein, aussi au XIXe siècle, corrige-moi si je me trompe, qu'on va aussi shifter
de l'antijudaïsme qui, peu à peu n'est plus accepté, alors qu'il n'était jamais remis en question vraiment jusque-là par les États, par l'Église.
On va shifter de l'antijudaïsme à l'antisémitisme qui va être inventé par, voilà, les personnes qui veulent pouvoir faire perdurer leur haine des Juifs.
Enfin voilà, l'idée, c'est qu'on va sortir du folklore et des contes et légendes avec les Juifs qui saccageraient les hosties, qui feraient le crime du sang, comme vous l'avez évoqué, etc.
Et on va passer sur des mythes basés sur la pseudo-science, la pseudo-biologie, donc les formes du crâne, ce genre de choses.
Alors, qu'est-ce que ça va avoir comme conséquence, ce shift ?
Faut faire attention sur une chose, c'est que-
Dites-moi.
Vous parlez en tant que Belge ou enfin... Non, non, mais autrement dit, ce que vous évoquiez qui est tout à fait juste, enfin, mais...
Vous seriez français ou allemand, ça serait la même chose. Vous parleriez en tant que Français ou Allemand.
Mmh, dites-moi.
C'est totalement correct, sauf que ça ne s'applique qu'à une partie du territoire européen, à savoir l'Europe occidentale,
où notamment les Lumières, plus la modernité font que la religion recule et que le poids du religieux recule dans nos sociétés.
J'ai oublié de préciser effectivement que je parlais plutôt de l'Europe occidentale.
Mais par contre, ce que vous avez évoqué ne s'applique pas du tout, par exemple, à la Roumanie ou alors à l'Empire russe, où là, toutes ces théories-là vont prédominer jusqu'au XXe siècle.
La Roumanie, l'exclusion des Juifs de la nation roumaine et des lois contre les Juifs, c'est jusqu'au début du XXe siècle.
Dans l'Empire tsariste, c'est la même chose.
C'est l'arrivée des communistes en Russie qui va remettre tout ça en question.
Exactement. Et en Roumanie, on va voir quasiment, il y aura pas de lois antisémites quasiment, dans une période très brève, entre la fin de la Première Guerre mondiale et le début de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Donc, vous voyez que selon les territoires, c'est vraiment très différent, l'Europe occidentale étant l'exemple que vous avez mentionné.
Donc d'une part, le rôle, le poids du religieux tend à disparaître. D'autre part, on rentre dans une période où la modernité prévaut.
Et donc évidemment que les accusations de crimes rituels deviennent absurdes en France. En Pologne ou même à Kiev,
au début du XXe siècle, y a un procès qui s'appelle le procès Beilis contre un juge de Kiev qui est accusé d'avoir enlevé et assassiné un enfant ukrainien pour récolter son sang, ce qui serait inimaginable en France-
Mmm-hmm
...en 1911.
Mais à partir de la fin du XIXe siècle, on va voir apparaître dans plusieurs pays, en Allemagne, mais aussi en France,
la France avec Édouard Drumont, des pseudo théoriciens qui, forts en plus du développement des nouvelles sciences, vont se targuer de parler du péril juif, et le terme va faire souche à partir de ce moment-là.
Mais en reprenant toujours cette idée, mais qui est centrale depuis le Moyen Âge,
c'est que les Juifs sont une menace, menace d'autant plus pernicieuse qu'ils vivent en notre sein et qu'on peut pas les reconnaître puisqu'ils ne se distinguent pas de nous, mais que pourtant, ils forment une race uniforme.
Et que là, on va commencer à théoriser l'idée raciale, c'est-à-dire que c'est le même groupe que vous trouviez à Bruxelles, que vous trouviez à Londres, que vous trouviez à Berlin ou dans tout autre point du globe, où les Juifs sont unis.
Et non seulement ils sont unis, mais en plus, ils travaillent tous dans le même sens. Autrement dit, le complot.
Ouais.
Avec toujours les mêmes choses. Les Juifs forment une race à part, on peut les reconnaître. Donc le gros nez, enfin tout ce que vous voulez.
Bah oui, mais j'allais justement vous demander. On a passé plusieurs minutes à expliquer qu'on ne pouvait pas les reconnaître.
Et donc là, y a une science qui explique qu'on-- une pseudo-science qui explique qu'on peut les reconnaître. Comment est-ce que ça peut tenir ?
Comment est-ce que ça peut fonctionner ?
Alors, vous pointez du doigt sans doute l'élément le plus important, c'est que vous cherchez à rationaliser quelque chose qui n'est jamais rationnel.
Si vous prenez les accusations antisémites, on vous dit que le Juif est laid et qu'en même temps, c'est un grand séducteur. C'est une menace-
Mmm
...pour vos femmes. On vous dit que le Juif contrôle l'économie, mais si vous regardez quelles sont les plus grandes richesses d'un pays, comme je l'ai mentionné tout à l'heure, vous n'avez pas de Juifs dedans, etc.
La rationalité n'a rien à voir, la réalité n'a rien à voir dans le délire antisémite.
On dit que ce sont de grands capitalistes et en même temps que ce sont des bolcheviques.
Des communistes. Voilà.
Oui, c'est ça.
Donc-
OK, alors on va arriver à ça
...est-ce qu'ils travaillent toujours pour leur propre intérêt ?
C'est ça.
Oui, parce que c'est un mythe, c'est quelque chose d'absolument construit et donc de pas forcément cohérent et en l'occurrence pas du tout.
Juste une question, donc, antisémite. Sémite, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça ne veut strictement rien dire. Là, c'est une perversion de la science avec plein de guillemets. On parle-- vous avez les langues sémites, un groupe de langues.
Vous avez pêle-mêle l'araméen, l'hébreu, l'arabe et même plusieurs langues éthiopiennes, donc, qui, pour les linguistes, constituent le groupe sémites.
Là-dessus, les théories racialistes de la fin du 19e siècle vont venir se saisir d'un terme qui n'est que linguistique, les langues sémitiques ou sémites, pour en faire des races.
Autrement dit, c'est absurde. C'est pas parce que vous parlez français que vous êtes de race française.
Oui OK. Donc c'est vraiment un mot pour, antisémitisme, pour vraiment se targuer d'être une science, d'être un mouvement intellectuel.
En fait, c'est une idée qui va être développée dans les années 1870, notamment par Wilhelm Marr, qui est réputé être l'homme qui a forgé le terme antisémite, même si c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça.
Wilhelm Marr se drape dans ces nouvelles théories raciales en expliquant que les Juifs constituent la race sémite. Y a pas d'autre race sémite.
Et qu'il faut lutter contre les sémites, entendu les Juifs, parce que les Juifs, c'est la religion, leur race, c'est la race sémite et qu'il faut lutter contre eux, donc être antisémite.
Et alors y a toujours une perversion qui est notamment pratiquée par les antisémites plutôt d'extrême gauche, qui vous expliquent qu'on peut pas parler d'antisémitisme puisque
y a pas que les Juifs qui sont sémites et que les Arabes sont, par exemple, la cible de l'antisémitisme également.
Ce qui est faux, les théoriciens de l'antisémitisme n'ont jamais parlé que d'une seule race, entre guillemets : les Juifs.
La même manière que-- comme si je vous disais : « Bah non, parmi les Sémites, y a les Éthiopiens ». En fait, non. C'est...
Ils parlent des langues-- tous parlaient des langues sémitiques et les racialistes ont inventé une idée, c'est que sémites égal Juifs.
Donc pour lutter contre les Juifs, il faut être antisémite.
On partait du constat que l'antijudaïsme, tous les mythes, tout le folklore, etc., ça perdait de son emprise en France à ce moment-là, puisqu'on parle de la France.
Est-ce que ce shift vers ce nouveau paradigme racialiste, raciste, est-ce que ça permet une résurrection de la persécution des Juifs ?
Est-ce que ça prend à grande échelle ?
Vous avez d'une part un mix entre l'antijudaïsme religieux qui reste très prégnant parce que les sociétés restent quand même très religieuses au 19e et au début du 20e siècle.
Donc, on continue à diffuser l'accusation, par exemple, du Juif responsable de la mort du Christ. Il va falloir attendre Vatican II pour que ça disparaisse de la liturgie, par exemple.
Donc, vous voyez que ça reste prégnant pendant très longtemps. Et en même temps vient s'accoler à ça l'antisémitisme en tant qu'idéologie qui se veut dépasser
l'antijudaïsme avec des guillemets, mais qui récupère tous les mythes antijudaïques et les développe puissance 10.
Donc cet élément-là, il est fondamental et ça va réactiver des violences, alors qui diffèrent selon les territoires. C'est-à-dire que si vous prenez la France, on va avoir épisodiquement des moments antisémites.
L'affaire Dreyfus, par exemple. C'est sans doute l'épisode le plus connu et l'acmé, le moment le plus poussé, mais y a eu d'autres épisodes antisémites avant.
Y en aura d'autres après. Là, je parle d'avant la Première Guerre mondiale. Mais si vous allez de l'autre côté du continent européen, en Russie, les années 1870, 1880, c'est le moment où les pogroms apparaissent.
Et d'ailleurs, c'est le moment où le terme de pogrom se diffuse à travers le monde. Et on attaque les Juifs massivement, physiquement, et on a des violences contre les Juifs.
Chose qui est très très peu le cas en France. En revanche, si vous allez en Algérie, territoire français à l'époque, vous avez un antisémitisme pogromiste qui est le fait des colons.
Et vous avez un antisémitisme très virulent en Afrique du Nord française, Algérie, Maroc, Tunisie, au point qu'Édouard Drumont va être élu député à l'Assemblée nationale, mais député d'Alger.
Parce que vous avez là un antisémitisme très particulier. C'est pour ça qu'en introduction, je vous disais, selon les territoires ou les régions, vous avez des attitudes et une prégnance très différentes et très variables en matière d'antisémitisme.
Donc, en France, on va avoir des moments de résurrection jusqu'au déclenchement de la Première Guerre mondiale, mais dans d'autres territoires,
en fait, on reste sur la ligne qui a toujours existé : les violences contre les Juifs, en Russie, en Roumanie ou même en Allemagne.
Alors, on va avancer encore un peu, beaucoup plus loin dans l'histoire. Donc, si on arrive au tournant de la révolution industrielle, puis de la fin du XIXe siècle.
Donc, comme je l'ai évoqué un peu plus tôt, le régime tsariste va tomber, le régime communiste arrive, qui lui, va être le premier à pénaliser l'antisémitisme.
Donc y a énormément d'évolutions à ce moment-là pour les Juifs en Russie. Y a aussi, au tout début du XXe siècle, la publication d'un livre conspirationniste : les Protocoles des Sages de Sion.
Alors, j'arrête mon curseur à ce moment-là de l'histoire. Qu'est-ce que c'est que les Sages de Sion ? Qu'est-ce que c'est que le sionisme ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est que l'antisionisme ?
Alors d'abord, c'est un plagiat pondu par les services secrets du tsar, puisqu'on est dans la période où l'Empire russe commençait à être secoué par des mouvements révolutionnaires à la fin du XIXe siècle.
Les services du tsar vont régulièrement déclencher des contre-feux en essayant de canaliser la population contre les Juifs.
C'est par exemple le cas avec l'affaire Beilis, que j'ai évoquée avant, 1911, à Kiev. Vous avez cette idée, mais qu'on va retrouver dans des dictatures jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
On l'a vu pendant les printemps arabes, en Syrie, en Libye, en expliquant que les troubles étaient fomentés par les Juifs ou alors, vous avez utilisé le terme, les sionistes.
Les Protocoles des Sages de Sion, c'est un faux qui a été forgé par les services du tsar en plagiant différents ouvrages.
Alors, le circuit est un peu compliqué, mais des romans et puis un pamphlet politique qui s'appelle,
Le Dialogue aux enfers, qui est un pamphlet contre Napoléon III, où les services du tsar vont quasiment plagier mot à mot certains passages,
s'inspirer aussi d'Alexandre Dumas et d'Eugène Sue, et utiliser des éléments romanesques,
et concocter un bouquin qui explique que les Juifs-- le bouquin se veut comme une présentation faite par un Juif d'un complot mondial mené par les Juifs, les Sages de Sion, qui se réuniraient dans un cimetière.
Et là aussi, c'est le plagiat d'un roman antisémite des années 1870, 1880, qui s'appelle à l'origine Biarritz, dont un chapitre va être détaché, dans lequel l'auteur explique que les Juifs se réunissent dans un cimetière à Prague.
Donc ça va donner lieu à la publication d'un pamphlet qui s'appelle Le Cimetière juif de Prague. Mais, donc les Juifs,
qui complotent pour dominer le monde, sont tellement cons qu'ils se réunissent dans un cimetière et pas dans un hôtel cinq étoiles à boire du cognac et à fumer des cigares.
Donc déjà, ça vous montre que scénaristiquement, c'est assez poireux comme idée, mais ce faux va être pris comme étant un vrai pendant des années.
Il va falloir que des Dominicains prouvent qu'on a affaire à ce qu'on appelle en anglais une forgerie, un faux qui a été constitué de toutes pièces.
Et pendant plusieurs années, ça va être présenté par une presse très sérieuse, parfois par des quotidiens et des journaux très sérieux, comme étant un ouvrage qui est peut-être un vrai ouvrage écrit par un Juif qui participe de ce complot.
Il va falloir attendre- ...ce qu'on pourrait qualifier de document historique. Et il va connaître une diffusion à l'échelle mondiale, d'abord en Russie, ensuite aux États-Unis, par l'entremise d'Henry Ford.
Et tout à l'heure, vous parliez de cohérence. Henry Ford, qui est une des principales fortunes des États-Unis à l'époque, estime que les Juifs contrôlent l'économie américaine.
Donc, vous voyez la déconnexion qu'il y a entre la réalité et le fantasme. L'un des hommes les plus puissants des États-Unis, Henry Ford, estime que l'économie américaine est contrôlée par les Juifs, alors que c'est lui qui la contrôle.
Et il va donc faire traduire et diffuser aux États-Unis le Protocole des Sages de Sion, comme ça va être le cas dans quasiment le monde entier, le monde occidental, pour aller vite-
Ouais, ouais
...avant que ça se diffuse dans le monde oriental beaucoup plus tard.
Ouais, et donc pour revenir à l'origine de ma question, donc le sionisme, l'antisionisme, comment est-ce que vous définiriez ça ?
Le sionisme, c'est un mouvement, alors qui politiquement a été théorisé par Théodore Herzl, mais qui est beaucoup plus ancien
et qui est l'idée que pour échapper aux persécutions en Europe, les Juifs doivent retourner vers le territoire dont ils sont originaires, historiquement la Judée, qui devient ensuite Palestine, etc.
Herzl appelle cela le sionisme, mais il y a toujours cette idée, là on revient sur un point qu'on a évoqué avant, c'est l'idée que le Juif est de nulle part.
En France, il est accusé d'être allemand comme Dreyfus, en Allemagne, il est accusé d'être polonais, et cetera, et cetera.
Mais dès le XIIe siècle, vous avez ce type d'accusation.
Une des premières accusations, ça va être notamment au moment, en Angleterre, au moment de l'affaire dite de Guillaume de Norwich, un gamin qui a été enlevé et tué, où on accuse les Juifs.
Et vous avez un moine, Thomas de Monmouth, qui va enquêter,
avec des guillemets enquêter, et prouver quelques années plus tard que c'est un complot juif, que les Juifs tous les ans se réunissent
à Narbonne, dans le sud de la France, et désignent une communauté pour sacrifier un enfant chrétien dans le but de reconquérir le territoire d'Israël.
Donc vous voyez que dès le XIIe siècle, on accuse les Juifs de tuer des enfants, mais pour pouvoir poursuivre un objectif très particulier : la reconquête du territoire d'Israël.
En fait tout au long du Moyen Âge, on va voir apparaître des mouvements quasi messianiques de Juifs qui veulent retourner vers la terre des origines.
Et Herzl, au moment de l'affaire Dreyfus, puisqu'il est journaliste
et à Paris, est témoin de l'affaire Dreyfus qu'il couvre pour un journal viennois, va théoriser ce qui est une tradition chez les Juifs, c'est-à-dire la volonté d'essayer de retourner s'établir.
Et y a des dizaines de milliers de Juifs qui vont le faire au Moyen Âge, puis plus tard. Là, ça devient un mouvement politique de fond disant : « On n'a pas d'avenir en Europe puisqu'on est en but avec--
à la persécution, soit d'État dans certains territoires, soit à l'antisémitisme prégnant au sein des populations.
Et nous devons donc, pour échapper à cette persécution, constituer un État et cet État doit être constitué dans notre territoire originel.
» Et c'est ça le sionisme.
Ouais. Et donc l'antisionisme, ce serait ?
L'antisionisme, il a été théorisé notamment par un grand démocrate, en l'occurrence Joseph Staline, puisque au sortir de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale, en URSS,
étant donné que l'antisémitisme a été disqualifié par le nazisme, on peut plus se revendiquer être antisémite au sortir de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Hm hm.
Staline, qui met en place des politiques antisémites même pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale elle-même, ne va plus officiellement promouvoir l'antisémitisme, il va promouvoir l'antisionisme.
Expliquer que le Juif qui s'oppose à sa politique est au service de l'étranger. Et on retrouve toujours cette idée du Juif traître qui est au service d'un territoire ailleurs et que
ces Juifs-là sont au service du sionisme, avec des guillemets, et donc il met en place des politiques antisionistes, mais que vous allez retrouver dans tout le bloc de l'Est avec toute une série de procès,
notamment un qui est très connu, qui est le procès de Prague, qui a inspiré un film à Costa-Gavras avec Yves Montand, qui s'appelle L'Aveu.
Où vous avez des Juifs qui vont être accusés de trahir le Parti communiste, de trahir l'État et la nation où ils vivent au profit du sionisme et de l'État d'Israël.
Donc l'antisionisme, c'est l'antisémitisme version communiste.
C'est l'antisémitisme qui ne dit pas son nom parce qu'on n'a plus le droit d'évoquer l'antisémitisme qui vient de faire 6 millions de morts.
6 millions de victimes.
Ouais, c'est ça. Oui, et donc là, on a effectivement-- on a fait un saut de mouton colossal, donc on va quand même revenir là-dessus.
Les fameux Protocoles des Sages de Sion va être introduit en Allemagne. Rosenberg va participer à la diffusion de ce livre.
Et c'est un livre qui va en partie servir d'explication à la défaite de l'Allemagne lors de la Grande Guerre.
Et ça prend. Y a des milliers de personnes, des millions de personnes qui trouvent soudainement des explications à des phénomènes qui dépassaient complètement leur compréhension.
Alors, je vais vous poser une question à 2 millions : qu'est-ce qui explique le fait que les idées qu'on trouve dans ce livre prennent autant et vont jusqu'à permettre le succès et le triomphe d'un parti nazi,
et la montée au pouvoir d'Adolf Hitler ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait dans ces idées-là que ça permet à un fasciste de monter au pouvoir ?
Alors, il faut relativiser, mais pas trop, l'importance des Protocoles. C'est pas les Protocoles qui expliquent l'arrivée au pouvoir des nazis.
En revanche, vous avez raison de souligner son importance parce que les Protocoles, jusqu'à aujourd'hui, sont diffusés dans
des grandes parties du monde et sont toujours pris comme étant un document, comme vous l'avez dit, historique, c'est-à-dire authentique, qui prouve la réalité du complot juif.
En fait, c'est un élément qui permet de conforter la pensée antisémite. On a la preuve que les Juifs complotent contre nous.
De mémoire, Hitler écrit à un moment que les Protocoles sont sans doute un faux, mais vu que c'est bien pratique, autant continuer à dire que c'est un vrai.
Donc, vous voyez que les grands antisémites ne sont pas dupes de la réalité du matériau, en l'occurrence de ce faux.
Mais l'Allemagne, alors, on pointe l'Allemagne sur l'importance de l'antisémitisme qui est évidemment une réalité. Il ne faut pas oublier qu'au même moment, vous avez une vague d'antisémitisme dans beaucoup de pays européens,
notamment en Europe centrale.
En France, cette vague va-- elle a-- l'antisémitisme a été mis à mal par 14-18 avec ce qu'on appelle l'Union sacrée en France.
Et au sortir de la Première Guerre mondiale, par exemple, l'antisémitisme a quasiment disparu du pays. En revanche,
on le voit réapparaître au début des années 30 en France, parce que vous avez tout un ensemble d'éléments, mais je vais revenir à l'Allemagne, ne vous inquiétez pas, qui viennent se mêler
et servir de terreau de réactivation à l'antisémitisme.
L'élément sans doute le plus important, c'est la crise économique de 1929.
Mmm-hmm.
Avec l'effondrement des économies, l'appauvrissement des populations. Et là, vous êtes dans un terreau qui est ultra-favorable à l'antisémitisme, puisque c'est de la faute des Juifs.
Vous avez là l'explication la plus facile à fournir s'il y a un problème. D'ailleurs, on le voit notamment avec la montée du parti nazi en Allemagne.
Dans les années 20, le parti nazi commence à avoir un certain succès dans un pays qui est traumatisé par sa propre défaite, avec l'idée qu'il ne pouvait pas perdre.
Et vous avez le développement de la théorie du coup de poignard dans le dos en Allemagne. On ne pouvait pas perdre. Notre armée était tellement bonne que la défaite militaire était impossible, mais on a été trahis de l'intérieur du pays.
Qui a pu nous trahir à l'intérieur du pays ? Évidemment, ce sont les Juifs.
L'utilisation de l'idée du Juif traître et du complot juif contre l'Allemagne, ce terreau-là, le pays est ruiné au sortir de la guerre et les circonstances font que la crise de 29 va venir achever cette situation catastrophique.
Et en fait, les nazis accèdent au pouvoir alors qu'un an avant, les précédentes élections
se sont révélées très peu favorables pour le parti nazi, par une conjonction d'un ensemble d'éléments qui font que la population allemande n'a pas voté pour les nazis uniquement par antisémitisme.
Et d'ailleurs, les historiens ont montré que même si l'antisémitisme est évidemment fondamental pour le parti nazi, ils n'en ont pas fait un cheval de bataille au moment des dernières législatives.
C'est-à-dire, les Allemands n'ont pas voté, non pas majoritairement, mais de manière très importante pour les nazis sur la seule base de l'antisémitisme en prenant en compte d'autres éléments.
Évidemment que l'antisémitisme est loin d'être désapprouvé par une partie importante de la population, mais c'est pas la raison pour laquelle ils ont adhéré au parti nazi, c'est pour d'autres préoccupations.
C'est-à-dire les problèmes économiques, de chômage, la pauvreté, la crise financière, le souvenir-
Le suprémacisme.
Pardon ?
Le suprémacisme. Le-
Oui, oui. Enfin, c'est vraiment la conjonction d'énormément d'éléments qui font qu'une partie des Allemands ont voté pour le parti nazi et Adolf Hitler.
Évidemment que toute la production littéraire de la fin du 19e siècle, ou alors les protocoles qui sont diffusés à partir du début du 20e siècle en Allemagne,
viennent sédimenter et jouer un rôle en faveur de l'antisémitisme qui devient de plus en plus important dans les années 20 en Allemagne et qui
même précède, en termes de violence, la prise du pouvoir par les nazis.
Par exemple, à Berlin, vous avez plusieurs pogroms, c'est-à-dire, on parle du cœur de la capitale allemande, en son centre même, vous avez des pogroms dans les quartiers juifs qui se trouvent pas très loin aujourd'hui du Bundestag.
Donc, vous voyez qu'on est vraiment au cœur de la capitale allemande. Il va y avoir des violences contre les Juifs parce que y a plusieurs quartiers juifs où vous avez des
populations juives, notamment récemment immigrées, qui sont présentes et qui vont être attaquées dans les années 20.
Donc l'antisémitisme n'a pas été imposé par les nazis, il est déjà présent et vivace à ce moment-là, tout ceci étant exacerbé par la situation du pays.
Et quand les nazis arrivent au pouvoir, ils arrivent au pouvoir dans un pays où l'antisémitisme est déjà vivace dans une partie de la société, au point qu'on s'attaque aux Juifs, y compris dans la capitale,
qui serait totalement hallucinant en France, par exemple, au même moment.
Vous pouvez avoir des bagarres entre mouvements antisémites d'extrême droite à l'époque et des Juifs, mais vous n'avez pas des pogroms, littéralement, où on va ravager des quartiers où les Juifs sont présents.
Et l'arrivée au pouvoir des nazis, qui n'est pas faite comme sur un programme politique où l'antisémitisme est en son centre.
Évidemment, Hitler veut s'occuper des Juifs, mais le cœur de son programme n'est pas là. Le cœur de son programme, c'est de dire : « Je vais redresser l'économie et
donner de l'emploi à tous les Allemands », etc., etc.
Mais à partir de l'accession au pouvoir, évidemment, l'un des premiers objectifs poursuivis, et qui est un objectif central pour les nazis, c'est la politique antisémite.
Donc, vous voyez qu'il y a un mélange d'énormément d'éléments qui font qu'on arrive à cette situation-là.
Merci pour cette clarification. Alors, on pourrait longuement parler de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et de la Shoah, l'extermination de six millions de Juifs.
Malheureusement, on n'a plus trop le temps, donc je vais avancer dans le temps. En fait, je vais avancer jusqu'à l'époque contemporaine
et vous demander ce qu'il reste de cet antisémitisme dans les partis fascistes, les partis d'extrême droite, les partis alt-right, voilà, peu importe leur nom.
Est-ce qu'on retrouve des discours antisémites ? Peut-être masqués, peut-être dissimulés, mais antisémites malgré tout dans les partis politiques contemporains ?
Alors, je vais répondre à votre question, mais avant, je vais souligner un point très important et très intéressant, c'est que là, vous évoquiez l'extrême droite
et cette idée d'associer l'antisémitisme avec l'extrême droite, en fait, c'est un héritage de la Shoah, enfin, du nazisme.
Mhmm.
Avec la Shoah, c'est-à-dire le pire projet antisémite de l'histoire, la destruction des Juifs qui a été réalisée par le régime nazi, au sortir de la guerre, l'antisémitisme est devenu étroitement associé avec l'extrême droite.
Or, l'antisémitisme n'est pas d'extrême droite. L'antisémitisme est réparti sur l'ensemble de l'échiquier politique.
En France, par exemple, la fin du XIXe siècle, la grande figure du socialisme, Jean Jaurès, tient des propos antisémites et même des discours antisémites.
Et il va falloir l'affaire Dreyfus pour que Jaurès fasse un aggiornamento sur l'antisémitisme au sein du socialisme en France.
En fait, l'antisémitisme, il est réparti à droite comme à gauche.
D'accord.
Et il faut pas le perdre de vue. Et justement, je vais revenir après avoir enfin répondu à votre question,
c'est que l'antisémitisme avait pendant très longtemps disparu du devant de la scène, disqualifié qu'il a été par la Seconde Guerre mondiale et par le nazisme.
Mais il a toujours été présent dans les discours d'extrême droite, effectivement, notamment si vous prenez la France, le Front national et Jean-Marie Le Pen ont passé leur temps à manier les symboles antisémites ou les allusions antisémites.
Et avant la naissance du Front national, vous avez d'autres mouvements comme le poujadisme, par exemple,
qui, là aussi, a multiplié les signaux en matière d'antisémitisme en attaquant, par exemple, Pierre Mendès France,
qui était président du Conseil, une grande figure de la vie politique française avant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et après, en l'attaquant sur le fait qu'il aurait, selon l'extrême droite, rajouté France
à son nom de famille pour se franciser.
On a affaire à une vieille famille de ce que j'appelais, enfin, ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure, la nation portugaise, une vieille famille française.
Vous voyez, y a toujours cette idée que le Juif n'est pas, ne peut pas être ontologiquement français, enfin, du pays.
Mhmm.
L'extrême droite ne s'est jamais départie de son antisémitisme, en tout cas, une partie de l'extrême droite. Une autre extrême droite va s'avérer
se revendiquer philosémite au sens où on aime les Juifs parce que les Juifs, à travers Israël, sont en guerre avec les Arabes et on déteste plus les Arabes que les Juifs.
Donc, on aime bien les Juifs. Mais c'est ce que vous avez vu se développer, notamment aux Pays-Bas à la fin du XXe siècle.
Ça a été théorisé par plusieurs leaders d'extrême droite aux Pays-Bas et on le retrouve dans différents pays tout au long de la fin du XXe siècle.
Donc l'antisémitisme avait été disqualifié publiquement par la Seconde Guerre mondiale et la Shoah.
Il a subsisté dans des endroits très contraints parce qu'il n'avait plus voix au chapitre publiquement, même si de temps à autre, on le voyait resurgir.
Et grâce ou à cause des réseaux sociaux et de leur développement, des discours qui jusque-là étaient tenus dans des endroits restreints se sont retrouvés de nouveau
sur la face publique pour une raison très simple : quand vous déversez votre bile au comptoir, y a que les types à côté de vous qui l'entendaient.
Quand vous déversez votre bile sur les réseaux sociaux, tout le monde peut y avoir accès. Les réseaux sociaux ont permis de connecter des gens qui étaient,
qui étaient séparés physiquement autour d'un discours qui n'avait plus voix au chapitre publiquement.
Donc, l'antisémitisme a rejailli à partir de la fin du XXe siècle, début du XXIe siècle, par l'entremise des réseaux sociaux et toutes leurs formes.
Aujourd'hui, c'est Facebook, Twitter ou TikTok, mais avant, ça avait été sur d'autres plateformes. Voilà. Et aujourd'hui, il devient de plus en plus évident, même si je parle de l'exemple français,
le resurgissement de l'antisémitisme a longtemps été nié.
Depuis vingt ans, il est patent. Mais en même temps, y a un autre élément et c'est pour ça que je me suis permis de vous reprendre et de souligner le fait que l'antisémitisme n'est pas forcément d'extrême droite.
On voit que dans les mouvements qui se revendiquent d'extrême gauche, il perdure toujours.
Et en France, par exemple,
aujourd'hui, le principal leader de la gauche, Jean-Luc Mélenchon, a commis des sorties antisémites régulièrement, tout en rétropédalant après, en expliquant qu'il n'est pas antisémite, qu'il n'a pas voulu dire ce qu'il avait dit.
Et le cœur de ses militants vous explique que c'est faux, c'est une disqualification, que c'est un coup des sionistes.
Les Insoumis sont très... ils appuient très fort leurs convictions quand on les embête et que—
Oui, oui.
...on challenge leur leader. Ils sont très bavards. Mais—
Oui, ils sont très vindicatifs, mais en même temps—
Oui, très susceptibles, ouais.
Ou... understatement, on pourrait dire en anglais, mais vous avez totalement raison. Mais voilà, vous avez une négation d'une réalité, mais la négation telle qu'elle est prodiguée montre
par contrecoup la réalité du truc, c'est qu'on vous explique : « Pas du tout, c'est pas des propos antisémites.
» Et d'ailleurs, si on les accuse d'antisémitisme, c'est bien la preuve que c'est les sionistes qui sont derrière ça. C'est le serpent qui se mord la queue.
Mhmm.
Qu'est-ce qu'Israël vient foutre dans un débat franco-français ? Ou alors, juste pour prendre un exemple pour vos auditeurs, Jean-Luc Mélenchon a expliqué que la défaite de Corbyn en Angleterre, c'était de la faute du grand rabbin d'Angleterre. Donc...
Ouais, OK.
Et une reprise à la fois de l'idée du complot. En même temps, quand vous demandez niveau cohérence, y a environ 300 000 Juifs en Angleterre pour un pays de 60 millions d'habitants.
Donc, vous voyez que ça serait le leader religieux d'Angleterre qui aurait provoqué l'échec de Corbyn. C'est une controverse.
Un leader religieux d'une minorité anglaise.
D'une minorité qui, par ailleurs, est loin d'être majoritairement religieuse. Enfin, tout est absurde, mais c'est pas grave.
On va vous expliquer que oui, c'est vrai. Donc voilà, vous êtes en plein dans l'antisémitisme dans ce qu'il a de plus pristin, mais en même temps, on vient vous dire que ce n'est pas antisémite.
Un autre mot qu'on entend régulièrement dans les discours antisémites, c'est cette notion de globaliste. Est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer cette opposition qu'on fait entre
les Juifs et finalement l'attachement à sa patrie, à son pays ?
Ça renvoie à l'idée qu'on a évoquée à plusieurs reprises, c'est que le Juif n'est pas du pays où il vit.
Mh.
Quelle que soit la réalité. Donc déjà, il y a cet élément-là. Il y a un autre élément qui est très important dans une partie de ces discours.
Vous avez des gens, et là, c'est plus du côté gauche, justement, que droite, qui vous expliquent qu'il n'y a pas de raison de distinguer le racisme de l'antisémitisme.
Ils en ont fait un fer de lance très fort. Or, c'est là où vous voyez la négation même chez eux de cet antisémitisme, c'est que le racisme part de deux présupposés
: nous, nous dominons les autres parce qu'on est blanc, par opposition aux Noirs, aux Asiatiques.
Donc ça, c'est le racisme. Ils nous sont inférieurs, on les domine et on les domine parce que racialement, on les reconnaît.
Le Noir est différent du Blanc. Et donc on assoit notre domination sur des êtres inférieurs. C'est la manière dont on définit le racisme.
L'antisémitisme, c'est exactement l'opposé. On ne peut pas reconnaître notre ennemi, le Juif, et en plus, il nous domine.
Ça a été expliqué on ne peut mieux par un des plus grands antisémites de l'histoire, à savoir Rudolf Höss,
le commandant du camp d'Auschwitz, qui, dans ses mémoires après-guerre, écrit en prison, explique que pour lui, l'antisémitisme est une guerre de libération, une guerre de libération contre la domination des Juifs.
Un raciste, lui, il veut asseoir sa domination sur des populations qu'il qualifie d'inférieures. L'antisémite, lui, veut se dépêtrer du joug qui est imposé par le Juif.
Vous voyez qu'on est dans des phénomènes totalement opposés, ce qui ne veut pas dire que l'un est pire que l'autre. Ça veut juste dire qu'on a des phénomènes opposés.
Et donc, si vous prenez la distinction de l'antisémitisme, vous avez des gens qui vous expliquent pourquoi est-ce qu'il faudrait distinguer l'antisémitisme des autres formes de haine.
Ce qui est une absurdité. La négrophobie est une forme de haine particulière.
Mh.
Comme l'islamophobie. Il n'y a pas de problème à utiliser ces termes-là. Mais vous avez des théories qui sont racistes. Autrement dit, la supériorité opposée à la domination.
Donc, vous avez cette idée-là. Le Juif, en permanence, n'en a que pour lui. Il nous emmerde avec son antisémitisme, sa Shoah, il est même pas de chez nous, etc., etc.
Mais vous n'avez pas que ce terme-là. Il y a des termes qui resurgissent régulièrement et qui font partie de ce qu'on appelle le whistleblowing, c'est-à-dire des signaux qui sont envoyés à ceux qui savent les reconnaître.
Par exemple, en France, on a vu resurgir lors de la dernière élection présidentielle un terme, l'oligarchie, qui est un terme qui est utilisé historiquement pour plein de choses.
On parle des oligarques en Russie, par exemple, ou en Ukraine. Donc le terme ne pose pas de problème a priori. Sauf qu'en France—
C'est l'idée que le pouvoir est aux mains d'une poignée de privilégiés.
D'une poignée... exactement. Mais en France, le terme d'oligarchie a été utilisé d'une façon très importante au XXe siècle par les antisémites.
Autrement dit, quand vous dénoncez l'oligarchie en France, les oligarques en France, vous auriez bien du mal à les identifier individuellement.
Vous renvoyez vers une abstraction. Cette abstraction, elle est simple à identifier. C'est toujours ce complot juif, cette mainmise des Juifs sur l'économie.
Donc le terme est réapparu à un moment où l'antisémitisme était de nouveau sur le devant de la scène au moment de la précédente élection présidentielle.
Et vous avez des termes comme ça, globaliste, oligarque, qui viennent en fait, du point de vue des antisémites, pointer une divergence qu'ont les Juifs par rapport au reste de la population.
Ouais. Tal Bruttmann, on arrive au bout de notre entretien. Je vais juste vous demander si vous voulez ajouter un dernier élément que vous voulez apprendre pour compléter, voilà, votre exposé sur l'antisémitisme.
Merci beaucoup pour votre temps. Et enfin, où est-ce qu'on peut vous retrouver ? Où est-ce qu'on peut vous lire ?
Alors déjà, je vous remercie de votre invitation. On pourrait, comme vous l'avez dit en introduction, en parler pendant des heures.
Oui, tout à fait.
Donc voilà, j'ai pas rajouté de points particuliers parce que je pense qu'on a couvert une bonne partie des aspects.
Mais enfin, il y aurait énormément d'autres choses à dire par ailleurs. Où est-ce qu'on peut me retrouver ? Dans plein d'endroits, ça dépend des périodes.
Mais j'ai écrit pas mal d'ouvrages et d'articles scientifiques. Donc il y a de quoi lire pour ceux qui sont intéressés par le sujet, moi ou d'autres spécialistes du sujet.
Très bien. Je mettrai les liens vers vos derniers ouvrages alors en description de ce podcast et je vous remercie encore une fois. Au revoir.
Merci à vous, au revoir.
J'espère que cet entretien vous a plu et que vous avez pu en apprendre sur la persécution des Juifs. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
C'est le dernier épisode de cette saison. Septante Minutes Avec reviendra à la rentrée avec des épisodes super quali.
Je recevrai une ministre de premier plan. Je vous livrerai le fameux épisode sur les troubles du comportement alimentaire que je vous promets depuis longtemps.
Il y aura énormément de changements qui vont arriver avec cette nouvelle saison en termes de prod, en termes d'identité.
Je ne vous dévoile encore rien pour l'instant, mais ça va être super. Et normalement, en août, je vous ferai un petit épisode solo, un petit édito.
Vous aviez été nombreux et nombreuses à me dire que ça vous avait plu.
J'en profiterai pour vous parler des coulisses, des changements à venir, revenir sur mon interview avec George-Louis Boucher, sur le cyberharcèlement que j'ai connu en janvier.
Plein de choses. En attendant, je pars profiter du soleil en Espagne, voir les Rolling Stones, les Red Hot et Jack White en concert.
Prendre du temps pour moi, mais sans vous oublier. Je vous raconterai tout, promise. Profitez bien et à bientôt. Salut !